teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
Ben Ayşe Kulin
cv'imi okutmak istemedim daha önceden
Çünkü çok net bir cv'im var Ayşegül'ün
Birgül yazar
Ben 6 yaşında Okuma yazmayı söktüğüm
andan itibaren yazmaya başladım
sesim iyi geliyor mu
80'li yıllardan sonra hatta 90'ların
içinde bir yayıncı bulduğum andan
itibaren de
yazdıklarım sizlerle buluşmaya başladı
ilkokulda şiir ortaokul yıllarında Öykü
lisede Roman denemelerin vardı ama
hiçbirini çok uzun yıl bir matbaacıya
sokamadığım için yayıncıya buluşmam
biraz geç kalmış oldu
ve ne zaman ki Ben hayatımı
yazdıklarımla kazanmaya başladım
yaptığım bütün diğer işleri bıraktım
onlar geride birer Hatıralar olarak
kaldı
epey de iş yaptım yani hakla
ilişkilerden tutun sadece kamera
arkasında çalışmak sahne yapınca gibi
dergi çıkarmak
tercümanlık çeviri gibi Ama onların
hiçbirinden artık alakam kalmadı
hayatımı yazarak kazanmaya başladım
bugün
öğrenciler için bir konuşma hazırladım
çünkü
29 Ekim'de 10 Kasım arasındaki bir
tarihteyiz ve bu konuşmayı
yapmayabilirdim Eğer Ben yazın Urla'da
oturduğumuz yazlık evimizden buraya
gelirken
komşumuzun kızı
Ortaokulu bitirmiş liseye gidecek
başlayacak O sene benim kütüphanemden
bir kitap istemeseydi benden bir
kitabımı istedi ben dedim ki nasıl kitap
seviyorsun Ne demek o dedi yani Aşk
romanımı maceramı polisiye mi tarihi mi
ya bir sürü kitap cinsi var ilk defa
okuyacakmış kitap şimdi biraz Şaşırdım
çünkü Ortaokulu bitirmiş bir çocuk
rahmetli annem yazdığını bizde geçirirdi
onu tanıyor Annem de her çok yaşlı insan
gibi hep geçmişini anlatırdı onlara
nasıl bir evde büyüdü ailesini falan
vedayı vereyim dedim dedemin konağında
geçen hikayedir Çünkü Yani kendini yakın
hisseder kitaba Dolayısıyla Belki daha
sonra gene başka kitapları okumak için
bir heves gelir içine dedim ki verirken
işte bu dedim nenenin büyüdüğü evi
anlatıyor neneyi de sen çok iyi
tanıyorsun Ayrıca işgal altındaki
İstanbul'u anlatıyor
yani O nasıl acılar çektiler Neler
yaptılar işte İngilizler gelip insanları
evlerinden çıkarıp girdiler
ne işgali dedi ne demek Ne bilmiyor
musun dedim Bir işgal olduğunu bizim
ülkemizde yok İlk defa duyuyorum dedi
sen yani
Gaziantep'in Fransızlar tarafından işte
Antalya'nın İtalyanlar tarafından
Ege'nin Yunanlılar tarafından alındığını
oralara şeyler kurulacağını İstanbul'da
zaten İngilizler var Bunları hiç mi
duymadın Peki tarih okumadınız mı
çocuğum Ben sayısal okuyorum dedi
şimdi tabii
sayısal okuyorsun Sen bu kitabı kitapla
başla dedim ona ve ben ona Kendi
çocukluğumu anlatmaya anlatmak istedim
Çünkü ben ikinci sınıftaydım herhalde
7-8 yaşında falandım Ankara'da ted'de
okuyordum
bayram günü 4 sınıfta başlardı bizim
zamanımızda tarih coğrafya din dersi
gibi dersler daha başlamamışız onlara
ama ya Cumhuriyet Bayramı ya 23 Nisan ne
hatırlayamıyorum sınıfı süslüyoruz işte
bayraklar krep ondan çiçekler yapıyoruz
asıyoruz falan Başöğretmen girdi odaya
ve Başöğretmen bize dedi ki; Yaptığınız
işleri bırakın ben size bugünün anlamını
ve ehemmiyetini önemini anlatacağım
başöğretmeni dinlemeye başladık
Başöğretmen işte size bu bildiğiniz
işgalden bahsetti padişahın yapabilecek
hiçbir şeysi olmadığını da söyledi çünkü
para yok yani o kadar borç gırtlakta ki
bütün kurumlarımız zaten yabancıların
elinde devletlerine Yolları Deniz
Yolları postane gibi bir devlet
kurumları hepsinin gelirleri onlara
bağlanmış Çünkü biz hep boş ödüyoruz
savaşmak için de para lazım silah lazım
orduyu beslemek lazım zaten orada 15
yıldır savaşta her tarafta savaşıyor
Dolayısıyla Yapacak bir şey yok ama
Mustafa Kemal Ee adında bir genç subay
işte Bandırma'ya bindi Samsun'a çıktı
Anadolu'ya indi o Eee silah altılan
ordunun
askerlerini toplamaya başladı
bulabildiği kadarını bir Ordu kurmak
için çünkü savaşsın
Tüm bu hikayeyi dinledik ve en sonunda
da 30 ağustos'u anlattı 30 Ağustos
zaferinden sonra Ordu Artık yavaş yavaş
yaya olarak İzmir'e doğru yürüyor 9
Eylül'de İzmir'e gelecek ve
Manisa'da son toplanıyorlar artık espire
yürümek üzere çadırda Mustafa Kemal
eline diyor ki Oğlum bak çadırın içinde
kitaplarım var bu kitapları topla bir
kutuya koy kutulara koy İzmir'e getir
beni Bulursun orada verirsin bana
kutu yok komutanım diyor nasıl Oğlum bak
işte Görüyorum orada kutular görüyorum
ben onların içinde silah var Komutanım
diyor silah varsa boşalt bir tanesini
mesela kurşunları boşalt içindeki
kitapları koy getir olur mu Komutanım
diyor ya yine savaşırsak Mustafa
Kemal'in cevabı şöyle Çok yakında yine
savaşacağız ama bu sefer silahlarla
değil cehaletle hastalıklarla ve yanmış
bizi artık mahsül vermeyen bitmiş
toprakla savaşacağız Sen Onları kutuya
koy bana getir diyor iniyorlar ve
gerçekten de ee cumhuriyeti kurduğu
zaman Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ün ilk işi
önce hastalıklarla Ama hastalık dediğim
zaman bütün Anadolu aklınıza gelebilecek
her türlü hastalıktan kırılıyor sağlam
insan kalmamış ağzında Dişiniz olan
insan kalmamış
frengiden tutun cüzdan sıtma ishal
trahom aklınıza ne geliyorsa perişan
Yani üstünden
devamlı Savaş geçen bir toprak
parçasında zaten yoksul köylü Toprak
derseniz yanmış yıkılmış hiçbir mahsulü
vermiyor bütün bunları toparlayabilmek
için önce hastalıklarla savaşıyor bir
kere sıkmayı yemiyor Adana'da her gün
kinin alarak yaşıyor İnsanlar bir müddet
bataklıkları kurutuyor arkadan eğitim
Hitlerin koyduğu çok değerli Yahudi
profesörleri getirtti Türkiye'ye ve
Türkiye'ye bir Rönesans yaşattı
müzik öğrenmek üzere dahi sanatı ihmal
etmeyerek dışarı öğrenci yolluyor
Neticede mesela 33 yılında İran Şahı
buraya ziyarete geleceğiz zaman İran
şahına
yani Türkiye'de tahmin etmeyeceğim
beklemediği bir şey yapmak istiyor işte
fabrikalara götürelim oraya buraya Yok
Onların hepsi İran'da var o kara istiyor
Opera O
halde Paris'e müzik öğrenmeye gitmiş
olan annen Saygun Opera yazıyor operayı
da kendi emrediyor Çünkü o kadar Bilgili
ve kitap okuyan bir adam ki iki kardeş
düşman olarak bilmişler birbirlerini
hayat boyu sonunda anlamışlar ki Meğer
iki kardeşmiş Bunlar barışıyorlar İran
Şahı İran şahına böyle bir şey sunuyor
İran Şahı da Sultan Selim'den beri zaten
sorunu savaşmamışız ama hiçbir zaman da
dost olmamışız komşu ülkenin başındaki
kişi böyle de incelikleri olan bir
Atatürk ama ben Bence en önemli devrimi
harf devrimidir ve kadınlara özgürlüğü
ve eşitliği tanımasıdır onun Yani onun
sayesinde bu
devrimin sayesinde Türkiye'yi 70'li
yıllarda Atatürk uçuruyordu neden
uçuruyordu çünkü kadınların
toplum hayattaki çalışma hayatına
katkısı
eğitim alanında diyelim ilkokuldan
üniversite sona kadar
temizlikçisinden profesörüne kadar yüzde
yetmişti
Finans sektöründe Yani bütün Finans
kuruluşlarında ve bankalarda çalışan
kadınlara yine temizlikçisinden müdüre
kadar diyemiyorum Çünkü Şube Müdürü
oluyordu kadınlar Bugün bile müdür Belki
çok azdır derken bir cam cam perde
gerisinde Erkekler oturuyor ama hiç
olmazsa Şube müdürüne kadar
çalışabiliyorlar %40 de eczacıların
%40'tı bu sayılar Avrupa'da yoktu böyle
bir sayı Amerika'da da yoktu ve Türk
kadını gene Avrupa'daki birçok devletten
önce İngiltere'nin haricinde hemen hemen
bütün diğer ülkelerden
çok daha önce kadınla seçme ve seçilme
hakkını verdi Atatürk kadınına erkekle
eşit olma eşit eğitim velayette eşitlik
her alanda eşitlik boşanmada da eşitlik
Çünkü kadın
Padişah Kızı olmadıkça zor boşuyordu
kocasını o Hakkı da verdi ve bunları bu
çocuğa anlatmak istedim
anlattım da şimdi buradan başka bir şeye
geçmek istiyorum
arkadaki gençler var zannedersem değil
mi önce Çünkü öğrencileri görmüyorum
arkada öğrenciler Yoksa bu bunu
anlatmamı bir anlamı kalmayacak
var mı öğrenciler
Biz benim kuşağım Maalesef bu
devrimlerin arkasında duramadı benim ve
benim çocuklarımın kuşağı biz derin bir
uykuya yattık her şey çok yolunda
gidiyor her şey tıkırında zannettik ve
hiç uyanmadı derin bir uykuda uyuduk Ama
bugüne geldiğimiz zaman bu bu rakamların
artık olmadığını görüyoruz kadınların
evlere sokulduğunu ve vazifelerini
sadece çocuk doğurmak çocuk bakmak
kocalarına yemek yapmak olduğunu
görüyoruz bunu da Kur'an'a
dayandırıyorlar Bu da Koskocaman bir
yanlış Çünkü neden Ben 4 sınıfa geçtiğim
zaman din dersine başlamıştık ve o kitap
gözümün önünde böyle pembe bir kapaklı
bir kitaptı yani toz pembe kapaklı ince
bir kitaptır Muhammed'in hayatını Hz
Muhammed'in hayatını okumuştuk orada
Muhammed'in eşi Hatice anamız
kervanları olan bir Tüccar hanımdı
zengin bir hanımdı ve yanında
çalışıyordu Muhammed onu kervanlarını
sevk ve idare ediyordu neymiş Demek ki
kadınlar Muhammed Peygamberin zamanında
ticaret yapabiliyormuş
hayatın içinde karılarından bir Zeynep
adını taşıyan
ayağa giymek için yemeni yapıyordu yani
yemeni Arapların ayakları yanmasın diye
giydikleri bağlanan deri parçalarından
onları iman ediyordu yani onları birkaç
arkadaşıyla birlikte yapıp satıyordu
neymiş Demek ki kadın Muhammed
peygamberimizin devrinde imalat da
yapabiliyormuş daha da ötesi var adını
taşıdığım Ayşe
Hz Aişe
en genç karısı sıfatında taşır aynı
zamanda ölümünden sonra çıkan mezhep
kavgalarında devesine binip savaşa gitti
ve savaş idare etti yani komutanlık dahi
yaptı onun için bu
safsatalarla milleti Uyutmaya gerek yok
Kur'an'da kadın çalışmaz kadın evinde
oturur sokağa çıkmaz diye bir bilgi yok
onlar tefsirlerle gelen bilgiler
dolayısıyla kadınların gene eski
kazanımına eski yerine gelebilmesi için
bizim kız çocuklarımızı okutmamız lazım
kız çocuklarımızı okutmamız için de ben
elimden gelenin Üstüme düşeni yapıyorum
bir kurum beni davet ederse okullar
Tabii ki değil ama kurumlar ve
belediyeler çağırdığı zaman bir Hakkı
huzur doluyor bir ödeme yapılıyor o
ödeme elimi dahi sürmeden olduğu gibi
Çağdaş yaşamayı oluyor
[Alkış]
şimdi Almanya'da okumalar yapmaya
gideceğim Onlar Cömert Onların da parası
İnşallah Çağdaş yaşamına gidecek Çünkü
her bir kız çocuğunu bu memlekette
okutmaya mecburuz ki bu bu halden
kurtulabilelim bu hale eee
çok daha önceden yani Cumhuriyet
kuruluşundan önce gören Osmanlılar fark
ettiler zaten Atatürk de onlardan
biriydi Neticede bu Savaşı Osmanlı
subayları kazandı Cumhuriyeti Osmanlı
subayları kurdu bizim 3 Selim Abdülmecid
gibi çok ilerici padişahlarımız var Ama
onların adlarına yazık ki köprülere
falan verilmiyor bugün onlar kadının
önemini anladıkları için bir de
düşündüler Yani bu hızla batan bir
geminin içindeler Bunun sebepleri var
sebeplerden bir tanesi kendini
yenileyememesi teknolojide sanayide geri
kalması bir ikinci sebepte
nüfusunun yarısını Müslüman nüfusu
yarısını yok saymış
tek bacağından böyle durursa Ben biraz
sonra düşerim ya da olduğum yerde zıplar
düşerim Nitekim öyle yapmış Osmanlı 15
15 Asır en parlak Devri Ondan sonra
olduğu yerde zıplıyor zıplıyor sonunda
düştü Çünkü Nüfusun yarısı yok
eğitilmiyor evde sokağa bile çıkmıyor ha
babam çocuk doğrusu veya kuma gelsin
Beraber yaşasınlar onursuz bir yaşam bir
kadın için
Ne diyeceğiz de
daha vaktin varmış
kısıtlı olduğu için çok çabuk konuşmaya
çalışıyorum
istediğim gibi anlatamıyorum Neyse dedin
formatı bu ben buna da razıyım
Dolayısıyla ben şimdi eğitime aktardığım
paraları çocuklardan da rica edeceğim
Çünkü
aranızda gruplar kurun
Anadolu'da yaşayan fakirlikten dolayı
okula ulaşamayan çocuklara yardımcı
olmaya çalışır kalem defter bile
yollasanız yeter ama onları aileler Eğer
muhafazakar oldukları için
göndermiyorlarsa o ayrı bir mesele oraya
bir şey yapamazsınız ama yoksulluktan
dolayı gidemiyorlarsa lütfen her
Birinizin bir kardeşi olsun devlet
okullarında pahalı okullar değil onlar
sadece üst baş kalem defter gibi küçük
paralarla bu çocuklar Çağdaş yaşamında
başl proje buydu zaten onların
eksiklerini kapatıp Yollarına devam
etmelerini sağlamaktı onu da buradan
Sizden rica edeyim benim kuşağım gibi
uyumayın Uyanık olun kadının yerini
kaybetmemesine bu cemaat içinde
yardımcı olur